welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by model actor this former
glamour UK cover stars mum Roberto how
are you doing
I feel somewhat vindicated on a personal
level just because what we're speaking
about in society at the moment is what
I've been speaking about for about three
years plus and people haven't always got
it so to be in a position now where my
work somewhat my life's work is now at
the forefront of the conversation I feel
good in that respect but also it's a
very very difficult time obviously
because we're in the midst of a virus
pandemic and people are dying and our
governments on you know doing good job
so it feels a very big paradox somewhat
some of the things that I've seen happen
and you've gotten social media over the
last couple of weeks days months like
one of the things that really hit home
to me what you have to deal with every
single day
is the amount of hate that you get like
I can't imagine what that's like to deal
with it must be so difficult for you how
have you learned how to manage trolls
and negative comments I mean is it's
sometimes really impossible to do when
they just feel as like a tidal wave
sometimes but honestly I think that the
biggest antidote to people hating on you
is knowing who you are as a person
because no one can take that away from
you you know just don't listen to it as
much as you can and focus on who you
want to be who you are and honor that
rather than you know who cares what they
have to say about you I mean it really
is a lot at the time just hurt people
wanting to hurt other people so that
they don't need to deal with their own
feelings if you deal with how you feel
and who you are then it just hurts a
little bit less how do you learn to
become up warm yourself in that sense to
not let that
- what's been some turning points in
your kind of discovery of your sense of
self as a trans person you're kind of
forced to your inform you find who you
are in a world that really doesn't have
any space for you and you're forced to
exist within the world that constantly
wants to tear you down and invalidate
your feelings invalidate your identity
invalidate your contributions invalidate
your possibility of having what we would
just call a normal life or in an
authentic life and trans people have
been navigating a hostile environment
our whole lives so now I feel like it's
all coming to a head and we can see
racism and facts and figures and stats
so the fact that you know black people
are 50% more likely to die than their
white counterparts you know we can see
the problems with police brutality not
only in America but also over here so as
a person of color as a black person as a
trans person as a queer person and as a
woman I've been navigating a hostile
environment my whole life so I do feel
like now that we're all confronted with
our phones much more than we were we're
not distracted I think that we're all
starting to see exactly what's wrong
with society how difficult has it been
for you to navigate your sexual identity
your gender identity and also your
racial identity all at the same time is
it is does it make it more difficult in
some aspects than others yeah I think
until I discovered intersectional
feminism I can't take away at my
queerness from my blackness from my
transness to whatever it's like you know
all of our parts of ourselves
impact on each other so until I
discovered that I really didn't connect
with feminism I didn't think it was for
me cuz it wasn't for me because it was
mainly focused around the rights of
white women and women who could produce
babies it was only really until I
figured out thought processes and work
that I'm now suggesting other people to
look into that I could really
no unpick my own identity and figure out
a way to cope with in a society that
really does invalidate every single part
of me on a level feminism really needs
to come to the fore right now also help
out trans people and be their allies how
has that been for you that Ally ship
from feminism have you felt like you
haven't received it before and now
you're receiving it more how's that been
I think it depends on what feminism you
follow unfortunately I think there's a
lot of really unhelpful feminism out
there such as the feminism you know JK
Rowling follows which is called gender
critical feminism which believes that
trans women are men and that the only
women are women that have a uterus which
is awful because a lot of women can't
have children and does that mean that
they're there less women because they're
no longer of use and it doesn't Center
the needs of black women of sex workers
of the people that really need feminism
the most which is the most oppressed
cross sections of society so I believe
that feminism needs to benefit you know
need to lift up people that are on the
front lines when it comes to sexual
violence which people that engage in sex
work whether or not this for survival or
traits but also trans women disabled
women people that are often overlooked
within society or have the least rights
need the most access to feminism it's
almost like we need to actually redefine
what this arcade idea of gender is I
think there's so many people who
subscribe to this binary idea of what
gender is as well like you know like it
has to be physical or it has to be
internal like it can be a mixture of so
many different things what gender means
to different people right like what does
the idea of gender in that sense mean to
you saying here today well I think that
a lot of people conflate sex and gender
when they're actually two different
things
well trans people aren't saying that we
were
and biologically female that's not the
tea you know that's not what we're
saying but then also we break down into
like what is female
you know if we're attaching identity to
genitalia but not acknowledging that if
you're born with say a vagina you may
not identify with your body we're just
assuming that that baby is going to
identify with their body and later life
and we don't know that so the reality is
is that the body that you're born with
may not be the body that you identify
later on so I mean for me gender
identity is as unique as you as we are
as individuals it's all about how you
identify it isn't about your body it's
not about what you were born with at
birth it's not necessarily about
chromosomes because sex is an binary
either intersex people exist in six kids
are being operated on and you know
without their consent without their
awareness about what's going on so
that's like a very different
conversation but that's also linked to
like the gender and sex conversation
it's very complicated in very in in many
ways but it's also very simple we just
need to allowing people to be who they
are what you you think has been the
biggest and most positive change in the
way we talk about trans people and what
the kind of stumbling blocks you're
still coming up against you know just
getting stuck on the same old
conversations such as trans women being
a threat to cisgender women and
acknowledging the reality of the trans
experience for women the reality is that
you know we're not attacking anybody of
like one or two trans women have their
crimes circulated and be the standard
for all trans women is really
traumatizing for us as a community and
it's really unfair we wouldn't say you
know because like school shooters we
wouldn't say that
all men like have the you know our
school shooters there's it's not there
it happens with gay men in the 1980s
where gay men were constantly referred
to as potential pedophiles or sexual
abusers and that's that's awful so in
many ways we're we're navigating the
environment that gay men were in in the
1980s unfortunately but our rights are
increased but even then even our rights
you know are on the table at the moment
how trigging do you find it then when
you see things like for instance like
the things that's been going on in
America with laws and and the rhetoric
like the very fierce rhetoric what's
going on how trigging has that been for
you when it comes to existing as a black
trans woman walking down the street and
constantly being called names and
constantly being treated like you're an
animal it's you know that's not
progressive to me so I've never
experienced the progression that say a
cisgender white male and who's gay
mullux you know because the gay rights
movement and the rights of gay men
especially white gay men have been
experiencing that very much like a
vacuum for that community but a lot of
the rest of the LGBT community being
left behind I'll a ship is such a big
term right now that we're all talking
about we all think how it could be
better allies different communities but
I've always thought when you look at the
lgbtq+ community there needs to be more
Ally ship with in it like is a serious
problem it's really frustrating because
I feel I really feel like a lot of this
white gay men within the community feel
like well we've we've got our rights we
you know we're good and it's it's very
much like they've been they've accessed
the power and the the goal was to access
power rather than access liberation for
like the whole community so I want to
see you know more people that have the
privileges within the community pulling
each other are we've all got privilege
in one way or another
it's about acknowledging what privilege
you've got and applying that to people
that don't have it my privilege is being
able to communicate but also having a
big platform that I can amplify other
people's voices so I think it's all
about using what you're good at and
applying that to other people yeah and I
think especially in an lgbtq+ community
we're not let liberate it until we're
all liberated right exactly it really is
that simple
and I I wish that there was more
compassionate across the world anyway I
think as well with allies ship we then
come into this other discussion that's
happening right now which is council
culture and kin is in so damaging in so
many different ways and I think you said
it's so powerfully when you have that
sit-down discussion with L'Oreal and you
came back and you actually said as an
activist part my work as encourage
businesses to understand the
responsibility and I think when you came
back to them
you had that discussion with them it was
so powerful like that is such an amazing
thing to do given all the things you've
been through as well how is your
relationship with this idea of council
culture changed and how do you think we
can get past the negative aspects of
council culture honestly it's out it's
gonna sound harsh but I really think
that council culture exists within an
echo chamber of ego it can only exist if
you are counseling someone on the basis
that you think that you are perfect and
I think it's such a freeing thing to
admit that you know you may say
something stupid on Twitter doesn't mean
that you're an awful person it just
means it it's something stupid I think
that we need to move from council
culture to accountability culture and if
someone refuses to take accountability
then that's really when we can talk
about you know not necessarily
cancelling them because you can't cancel
somebody you can't just send them off to
an island and there exists no you can't
stop that but we're not communicating
with each other we're just cutting each
other off and hoping that one party will
cease to exist and sometimes that is
necessary with you know people being
banned from Twitter but that's not
necessarily cancellation that is
again accountability but you are the
first trans person to ever appear on the
glamour cover globally yeah oh that's
bad
that's such an amazing thing how much do
you think that hovering particular
would've spoken to you the younger you
and how it helped you well I didn't
really have any trans role models that I
could relate to when I was a kid oh my
god something really exciting happening
of the day and Nadia from I spoke to
Nadia from Big Brother from know and I
god I can't big icon so she was like the
only trans woman that I saw when I was
growing up was just herself and the
nation fell in love with her and then
unfortunately she was torn apart when
she left the house so it was very much
like you could see the duality of public
opinion being positive and seeing a
trans person for the person that they
are
and then the media being extremely
transphobic nationalist and conservative
and not wanting a trans person to
succeed apart from that there wasn't any
trans representation there was like you
know trans people getting heckled on
Jerry Springer on Maori on Ricki Lake
and being called freaks
and then there was Haley from Coronation
Street god bless her she was lovely but
she wasn't played by a trans character
she was like patty something your old
woman and I was like again a 16 year old
child so I'm just in many ways trying to
be the representation that I wish I had
seen when I was a kid and trying not to
you know ever put myself in a position
of affection or trying to make people
fit see me as you know I'm not trying to
assimilate into a culture I'm trying to
bring trans culture and bring black
culture and bring queer culture in an
authentic way to people that haven't
seen it before I'm not in I'm trying to
be myself this is one of the most
powerful at
changing times we have ever had for you
personally what is the one lesson or
positive you want to take away from 2020
I think it's you know always try and
find the positive in difficult
situations and there in mind that things
may not go your way but figuring out how
to navigate that situation and something
better will grow out of it we've seen
spice of interest in PLM and trans
rights in the public sphere before and
we've seen it every scene it floats on
up it's gone down do you feel like the
momentum is gonna keep up now I think
you can just feel it you can feel that
this is different the protests haven't
stopped they're not slowing down the
accountability and the organization and
mobilization of our generation and the
generations below what would you like to
see in the workplace to make it more
inclusive and welcoming I think it
really comes down to minorities in
decision-making roles yeah not just you
know my not being hired in say the
intern position or the lower-level
position I want to see black people do
in the hiring I want to see black people
making the decisions I want to see all
kinds of people in the room making the
decisions and calling the shots you
create a better product that is
appealing to all people if all people
are in the room to create the product in
the first place
so I think if we're looking to create
sustainable diversity and inclusion then
it has to be at every level it has to be
authentic and it has to be progressive
and constantly evolving so that every
single issue is covered it's been so
amazing listening to you talking to you
I mean I think I can speak to you all
day so
you